مشاهدينا مرحبا بكم في هذه الفقره
التحليليه لمجريات الحرب حرب اسرائيل على
قطاع غزه وفيها نستضيف المحلل العسكري
اللواء فايز
دويري بدايه مشاهدينا نتابع اخر تطورات
المشهد ميدانيا في قطاع غزه على الخريطه
التفاعليه مع الزميله سلام خضر سلام لك
الكلمه والحديث اليوم عن استمرار المعار
عن سيطره كما تقول اسرائيل سيطره عسكريه
على عدد من المناطق لا سما حيه الشجاعيه
صحيح هذا ما اعلنته قوات الاحتلال حسن
ولكن لن نبدا من داخل قطاع غزه سنبدا مما
جرى من قطاع غزه باتجاه الاراضي
الاسرائيليه اذا في اليوم
السادس للحرب الاسرائيليه على غزه كتائب
القسام تثبت انها ما تزال تملك القدره
الميدانيه ليس فقط على صد الهجمات
والمواجهه مع الجيش الاسرائيلي داخل قطاع
غزه بل ايضا استهداف الاراضي داخل اسرائيل
اليوم قالت القسام انها اطلقت رشقه من
الصواريخ اكثر من
35 صاروخا اطلقوا من داخل قطاع غزه
ووصلوا الى مدينه تل ابيب والى عدد من
المدن المجاوره المدن والبلدات
المجاوره تل ابيب ريشون ليسيون قريب منها
وايضا قريب من الرمله هذه المناطق يعيش
فيها اكثر من 3ه ملايين اسرائيلي كانوا
اليوم في حاله هلع عندما اطلقت هذه
الصواريخ من قبل كتائب القسام بينما كانت
هذه الصواريخ تنطلق الوضع الميداني كان
متصاعدا داخل القطاع سنبدا من المنطقه
الشماليه حيث تدور المعارك
الاقصى كما يقول الجيش الاسرائيلي يواجه
مقاومه قاسيه وضاره من قبل كتائب القسام
وفصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه قبل قليل
الجيش الاسرائيلي قال انه سيطر ميدانيا
على منطقه الشجاعيه سيطر عملات عفوا وليس
ميدانيا ربما نفهم به هذا الامر بانه قد
لا يكون سيطره بريه كامله وانتشار لقطاعات
الجيش داخل منطقه الشجاعيه او انه على
سبيل المثال قد اسقطها بالنار بمعنى انه
اوقف حركه المسلحين بداخلها لم يوضح الجيش
الاسرائيلي حقيقه ما يجري في حي الشجاعيه
قال فقط سيطره عمل نيه ولكن ايضا في
قلب المناطق الوسطى الان ننتقل الى مدينه
غزه تحديدا اليوم اهالي قطاع غزه او اهالي
المنطقه الوسطى تحدثوا عن ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي استهدف مربعا سكنيا كاملا وقام
بتفجيره ولم يتم تبيان حقيقه ما جرى
بالضبط نظرا لانقطاع الاتصالات داخل
القطاع وخاصه في المناطق التي تشهد قتالا
ولكن قبل قليل قبل نحو ساعه من الان الجيش
الاسرائيلي وزع صورا لما قال انه تدمير
لشبكه من الانفاق ومقر لقياده حركه حماس
وكتائب القسام وهي عباره عن ابنيه وتحتها
انفاق وتمتد طوال الشارع والى ما يعني
اعطى تفاصيل وقدم تفاصيل ال والصور تظهر
تفجير عدد كبير من المباني ربما تقريبا في
هذه المنطقه في المنطقه يعني الشماليه
الغربيه من قطاع غزه في دوار فلسطين تم
تدميره ربما الدوار مع الابنيه المجاوره
له في
تفجير يعني استمر لبضع ثواني وكان متنقلا
لمجمع سكنيين على الاقل حتى الان لم يتم
معرفه ما هي هذه ابرز هذه الاضرار التي
نشبت عن هذا التفجير في الختام فقط نقطه
ان من طقه الجنوب خان يونس بالتحديد تشهد
اشتباكات وال القوات الاسرائيليه تهاجم من
اكثر من محور لكن لم تطوق خان يونس والان
تقول القسام قبل دقائق دقائق انها استهدفت
مجموعه من الجنود الاسرائيليين في خانيونس
حسن هذه بسرعه ابرز ما جرى اليوم في
القطاع ومن قطاع غزه اخترتي البدايه من
الصواريخ على تل ابيب وسابدا معها ايضا
بالتح تحليل مع اللواء فاز الدويري سيطر
اسرائيل على العديد من المناطق كما تقول
لا سيما في الشمال على حد قول المتحدث
العسكري لكن الصواريخ ما تزال تصل الى
تلبيب نعم وهذه اشاره واضحه لدحض
التصريحات
الاسرائيليه عندما يقول سيطره على
الشجاعيه سيطره على كذا في هذا المساء هذا
اليوم كان هناك
مقتل 11 جندي في التوام
و ثم سته جنود ثم الجماعه او المجموعه
التي جاءت لمساعده ال 11 جندي ثمانيه
كانوا بين قتيل وجريح هؤلاء في التوام مع
الان هل سيطره على بيت لاهيه بالامس كان
اشتباكات بالرشاشات هل سيطره على جحر
الديك انا اتحدث عن مناطق دخلها في اليوم
الاول من الحمله البريه اي دخلها قبل 52
يوم الان فيما يتعلق بالشجاع ومن ثم اذهب
الى اطلاق الصواريخ تصريح القسام كان واضح
جدا القتال في المنطقه الشماليه الشرقيه
من الشجاعيه ليس في قلب الشجاعيه وتحدثنا
كثيرا وعلى الخارطه بانه دخل من شارع
بغداد الى شارع صلاح الدين انعطف جنوبا
وتوقف ثم عاد وانكفى واصبح قتال ما بين
اي شارع بغداد وشارع المنص المنصوريه
المنصوره اذا دعني اقول التصريحات
الاسرائيليه تتعارض مع المنطق ومع الواقع
المجسد على ارض على ارض الواقع نذهب الى
نقطه اطلاق الصواريخ هل يعقل ان ت يطلق 35
صاروخ بماديات اكثر من 70 ر يصال يطال
مطار اللد وليس مطار بن جوريون وي يطال
بيت يام و تل ابيب هل يعقل ان يتم في ظل
هذا القصف الجوي المحموم والمدفعي على
مدار الساعه ان يتمكن القسام لو كان هناك
سيطره حقيقيه على اطلاق هذه الصواريخ لا
هو الان عندما يطلق الصواريخ هذه الصواريخ
عندما تذهب الى تل ابيب هي تتم بتنسيق
هكذا اقرا ما بين البعد السياسي واعلى
مستوى في البعد العسكري لانه الهجوم
الاسرائيلي هو تنسيق بين البعد السياسي
والعسكري للضغط على المفا لتوضيح اطلاق
الصواريخ ماذا يستلزم يعني حتى يفهم
المشاهد ونفهم معه ايضا
اي كيف كيف يتم التعامل حتى في المناطق
التي تقول اسرائيل انها سيطرت عليها
الاسبوع الماضي كان القتال على اشده في
مخيم جباليا ام وكان يقول سيطرنا على مخيم
جباليا وتم اطلاق الصواريخ من مخيم
جباليا مما يدحض الادعاء الاسرائيلي الان
كيف تطلق الصو اين هي الصواريخ هل القواعد
الصاروخيه موجوده فوق الارض ام تحت الارض
هي موجوده تحت الارض هناك 1300 نفق 500 م
من الانفاق انواع الانفاق متعدده استطعنا
الحصول على معلومات من مواقع مختلفه مقسمه
بين انفاق دفاعيه انفاق هجوميه انفاق
لاغراض التصنيع انفاق لاغراض عقد
الاجتماعات مبيت الى غير ذلك نذهب الى
الانفاق التي تستخدم من اغراض اطلاق
الصواريخ نعم انا كقراء تحليليه تنسجم مع
الواقع هذه الصواريخ لو كانت فوق الارض
لدمر قواعدها بعد اطلاق النار لانه يتم
رصد الهدف من خلال الرادارات الان ماذا
يجري هذه موجوده تحت الارض تتحرك بطريقه
الماء سواء على العجلات او على سكه
وبالتالي تصل الى نقطه الاطلاق وهي تحت
غطاء ال النفق مغطى الان يتم فتحه
هيدروليكيا
يتم رفع الصواريخ بمسافه 50 سم او اعلى
قليلا تصبح فوهه
الاطلاق بزاويه معينه يتم اطلاق الصواريخ
يتم تجهيزها لانه الامور تعتمد على
الاحداثيات يتم تجهيزها و يتم توجيه يعني
لا دعني اوضح نقطه يتم اجراء كافه الاعمال
قبل ان يتم فتح الفوهه في اللحظه المناسبه
لحظه الاطلاق تنفتح الفوهه تطلق الصواريخ
تغلق يتم تحريكها من
النقطه ولهذا السبب هذا سبب نجاعه اطلاق
هذه الصواريخ هذا يتطلب منظومه قياده
وسيطره فاعله
وتغذيه راجعه من مصادر
استخباريه تعطيهم المعلومه الكامله ان
الاجواء خاليه من الطائرات خاصه طائرات
الرصد والاستطلاع والتصوير وهذا يعني ان
منظومه القياده والسيطره وهيئه الركن لا
يزال يدير المعركه بن جاعه طيب اي لنعود
من جديد الى الشجاعيه نعم
اي موضوع الشجاعيه ومدينه غزه اولا ما
اهميه الشجاعيه عندما يتحدث جيش الاحتلال
عن السيطره
العمليات عليها هو اذا اذا قصد السيطره
العمليات هي السيطره بالنيران فهو يسيطر
على غزه كامله نيران ليس الشجاعيه يعني
الان عندما نتحدث عن عرض قطاع غزه في
مجمله كمتوسط عام 7 الى 8 م طوله 42 م نعم
وبالتالي حتى لنعد الى الخريطه يعني
هذه هذه تلبيب لنعد الى الى الخريطه بعد
بعد قليل يمكن نعم هذه هي الشجاعيه هذه هي
الشجاعيه لماذا الشجاعيه الشجاعيه اولا
يوجد فيها كتيبه الشجاعيه وتصنف على انها
احد كتيبتين يطلق عليهما القوه الضاربه
وهي الشجاعيه والتفاح لديها سجل
حافل مع لواء جولاني ومع الجيش الاسرائيلي
تحديدا
2014 وهناك حقد تاريخي قائد الكتيبه الذي
قتل وتم استبداله بقائد كتيبه قتل بعد 24
ساعه له فيديو نشر يتحدث لجنوده عن ضروره
تدمير الشجاعيه هؤلاء جنود هم يقولون حسب
هذا الشريط الذي وزعه الجيش الاسرائيلي
انهم في حي الشجاعيه قد يكون في حي
الشجاعي لكن في اي منطقه من حي الشجاعيه
انا اقول لك المعلومات الوارده والمعلومات
التي ترقى الى درجه او يعني مبنيه على
مصداقيه عاليه جدا القتال في الجزء
الشمالي الشرقي من الشجاعيه من من شارع
المنصوره الى شارع بغداد حتى لانه شارع
بغداد يقسم الشجاعي هي ثلث بثلث ثلث شماله
والثلثين الجنوب لو كانوا يتحدثوا لقالوا
وصلنا الى تله المنطار ل وصلنا الى حي
التركمان وحي الاكراد وبالتالي لا هم
يقاتلوا في الجزء الشمال الشرقي وهذا ما
ذكره القسام وهنا انا
يعني جمله
واحده لماذا اتبنى وجهه نظر القسام ليس
لانها القسام وهي تستحق لكن لان انها تقدم
الدلائل الملموسه التي تدعم بها التصريحات
عمليا هذه عمليات تمشيط كما كما نفهم هذه
من جانب واحد هذه الان هل تقول لي انها في
الشجاعيه هل هي في بيت
حانون نحن نتحدث عن اطار صوره محدد وهذا
الاطار المحدد لا لا يعطي المشاهد اين هي
طبيعه المنطقه وبالتالي اذا قال لي في
الشجاعيه لن اصدقه اذا قال في بيت حنون لن
اصدقه لن يعطيني اطار صوره محصور لا
استطيع اني انا ابني عليه اين هو محور طيب
هذا في الشجاعيه لننتقل الى غزه يقول جيش
الاحتلال
انه تمكن من تدمير مربع القاده مربع
القاده ل ل حركه حماس كما ذكرت سلام قبل
قليل هذه المنطقه هي على الاقل فيها اربعه
ابنيه كبيره وكان ال الاصوات الانفجارات
يعني تكررت و على اكثر من عمل عمليه
التفجير المباني هذه امر طبيعي جدا اي
سلاح هندسي في العالم ي هو سبق ان حصل لا
لا يعني هذا هو انا كنت مدير سلاح هندسه
هذه هذه
الصور انا كنت مدير سلاح هندسه عمليه
تدمير المباني هذه شغله سهله جدا وبسيطه
جدا ام اي اي فريق هندسي يستطيع ان يوزع
الحشوات
بنظام معين ومن ثم يربطها بدا دائره
كهربائيه و بكبسولات لكن هو هو جيش
الاحتلال يقول
انه مركز القاده وليكن وليكن يعني ام انا
استغرب يعني لنفترض انه كانت هناك مباني
للقياده مباني القياده اين هي تحت الارض
وكل مبنى قيادي يوجد له مباني بديله عندما
يتم الان في المعركه الدفاعيه وخاصه في
الحرب غير متناظره في المدن انا يكون لدي
اكثر من قياده بديله اذا هذه القياده
تعرضت للقصف واصبحت خارج العمل هل ينشل
تنشل قدرتي على اداره المعركه ام يوجد لدي
بدائل
استيك ذ افهم منك انه حتى لو كانت هذه
مباني للقياده فتدمر لا يعني شيئ لا لا
يعني شيء لا ي من وجهه نظر عسكريه لا يعني
شيء اذا دمرت هذه القياده هل هل تنشل
قدرتي على اداره المعركه ماذا عن في
الحروب التقليديه ماذا عن اذا انا كان لي
حديث مع قائد الفت هوك في عمليه اي عاصفه
الصحراء
وكان كان اثناء دوره اداره العمليات
المتقدمه وطرحت عليه سؤالا محددا
عن طبيعه تصرفه وكيف يقضي ساعات يومه
اثناء المعركه واعطاني تفصيلات كامله عما
جرى مع و خلال حرب ال ساعه البريه انني في
اليوم الاول كنت اعمل كذا واعمل كذا
وبالتالي كان في في كان في عربه قتال
متحركه ويدير المعركه من عربه القتال
المتحركه هنا اداره المعركه هي من الانفاق
وبالتالي كل قياده لها قياده بديله ولها
قياده احتيار طيب
اي لو انتقلنا الى جبهه
الجنوب جبهه الجنوب لغايه الان لا تغيير
في خطوط المعركه ال الهجوم الذي جاء من
الشمال من كفيم الى القراره وتحرك باتجاه
شارع صلاح الدين وانعطف الى المطاحن وذهب
الى ابراج الحمد لا يزال متواجد في تلك
المنطقه والهجوم الذي جاء من الفخاريه
باتجاه من جنوب بني سهيل بني سهيله لا
يزال متعثر والقتال لا يزال شرق شارع صلاح
الدين طيب هناك يعني كثيرا ما نسمع ونتابع
اخبارا حول المعارك في خانيونس دعني اقول
هي شرق خانيونس هي في بن سهيله في الزنه
في عبسان الجديده في عبسان الكبيره في
الفخاريه يعني هناك محاوله لفرض طوق خارجي
بعيد نسبيا على مدينه لانه مدينه خانيونس
تقع الى الغرب من صلاح الدين في جلها
بينما شرقها هي بني سيله وزنه وعبس
الجديده وه هذه المجموعه وبالتالي هو حاول
من مدينه حمد ان يطوق وان يذهب باتجاه
منطقه المواصي ومنطقه
المستعمرات الاسرائيليه القديمه قبل ان
يتم ازالتها كمان هو يحاول ان يقطع خان
يونس عن مدينه رفح يحاول ان يفرض تطويق
ولكن معركه مدينه خان يونس
[موسيقى]
كمعركة يحول ان يسيطر على المناطق
الزراعيه في الشرق وفي
الجنوب يحا ان يسيطر على المناطق في الشرق
وفي الجنوب وبتالي يعز الرف الغزيه عن
الرف المصريه طيب ايضا فيما فيما يتعلق
بيات القصف على الرم من حديث قوات
الاحتلال اود ان انوه الى الخبر العاجل
الى انه وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه
تقول بانه تم سحب لواء جولاني من غزه بعد
60 يوما من القتال تكب تكبد فيها خسائر
كبيره وكنت تتحدث عن لواء جولاني وعلى
اعتبار انه من قوات النخبه الان تم سحبه
يا سيدي لواء جولاني حتى اوضحه هو تنظيمه
خاص يوجد به ثمانيه كتائب اي يعادل لوائين
اربع كتائب هو من طلاب المدارس يوجد بها
اربع كتائب دبابات كتيبتي مشاه كتيبه
مظليين كتيبه مدفعيه اسلحه الاسناد
العمليات وعمليات الامداد
والصيانه متى يتم اخراج الوحده من القتال
هذا سؤال وهذا ستاندرد عالمي ام اذا تم
سحبه فقد 40% من قدرته القتاليه البشريه
والمعدات
هذه قاعده
درسناها ودرسناها يعني الان يمكن ان نقول
ان لواء لء جف عادي خرج من العمل عندما
يقول تم سحبه بسبب الاصابات لواء جولاني ن
عفوا لواء جولاني عندما يتحدث تم سحبه لا
يمكن لوحده ان تسحب من المعركه قبل ان
تفقد 40% من قدراتها القتاليه البشريه
والمعدات الان نذهب الى تشكيله ثمانيه
كتائب ماذا يعني معنى ذلك الان يمكن ان
نستنتج من وجهه نظر عسكريه ان قوات
الاحتلال فقدت
40% قد هذا اللواء لواء جولاني الذي يعتبر
من قوات النخبه وبالتالي تم سحبه لانه
عمليا اعطب انتهى الان
عندما عندما تفقد اي قوه هذا في الجيوش
المحترفه
التي تستند في ادارت للمعركه على مرتكزات
علميه خلاصه الحرب العالميه الثانيه اذا
فقدت اي وحده 40% من قدراتها القتاليه
البشريه والماديه تصبح خارجه عن ال هل
يمكن هل يمكن فقط بهذا ال بالحديث العسكري
الان هذا اللواء اذا كان هو لواء النخبه
وحصل به ما حصل ماذا بالتالي ماذا عن باقي
الالويه وبالتالي نعود الان الى تصريحات
ابو عبيده قبل قليل تحدث عن 720 اليه تم
اعط 720 اليه الان اللواء يوجد فيه 105
اليات عمليات من 97 الى 105 عندما يتحدث
عن 700 هو كانه جرد سبعه الويه من معداتها
القتاليه لكن الرقم الاجمالي ليس 720 720
هذا الرقم الذي يتعلق بقوات القسام انا
بالامس قرات تقرير كان الرقم
998 مع ما حدم حث اليوم تخطى عتبه
الالف السؤال الان ام الان نحن نتحدث عن
ماذا يعني سحب هذا اللواء ماذا يعني ان
يعطب هذا اللواء ان يفقد اكثر من 40% من
من قوته لكن ماذا يؤثر ذلك على على مجريات
المعركه عموما هو يعني دعنا نكون واقعيين
تم حشد اربعه فرق ام وتم تعزيزها بتسعه
الويه من من مناطق الوسط والشمال بينها
جفعاتي وجولان وناح ولواء المظليين وقوات
الكوماندوز الى غير ذلك لا يزال لديه قوه
لا يزال لديه حتى فائض قوه يعني لا انكر
ذلك لكن لواء فقط هنا اللواء جولاني يعتمد
عليه في في ان يكون راس حربه بالتقدم و
وفي التوغل السب لهذا السبب لانه راس حربه
تم اي تحمل الصدمات الرئيسيه في في
المعركه وهذا هذا هذا شهاده
براءه على شده المعارك وعلى حجم الخسائر
وبالتالي اذا كنت اذا كان اي ليست انا اذا
كان غيري لديه ضبابيه وشكوك حول ارقام
القسام اعتقد الان الجانب الاسرائيلي هو
الذي ايد تقارير القسام وبالتالي هذا
اللواء المتميز الذي اسس عام
1948 وللعلم لماذا سمي جولاني نسبه الى
الجليل وليس الى الجولان لانه اسس في ال
48 واشتق اسمه جولاني من الجليل وهذا شارك
في ال 48 قبل تاسيس جيش الاحتلال الان
عندما تخرج يخرج احد قوات النخبه واللواء
الاميز والذي له تاريخ وسجل في الاجرام
يخرج عن العمل هذا هذا مؤشر على طبيعه
المعركه ودراوه المعركه ونجاح قوات القسام
وبقيه الفصال الجهاد الاسلامي في اداره
معركتها بعد مرور 53 يوم على المعركه
البريه نعم اذا اردنا ان نتحدث هنا عن
المعنويات يعني حتى لو كانت هناك فرق
والويه اخرى ما زالت تعمل لكن ان يخرج
ال الاميز والذي يتم التمثل به والذي
يعتبر النموذج وراس الحربه عندما يخرج من
المعركه باي
باي نفسيه او باي معنويات سيعمل الجنود من
الالويه والفرق الاخرى حال وصول الخبر
اليهم يعني يا ريت انه اطرح هذا السؤال
على رئيس اركان جيش الاحتلال وعلى وزير
الدفاع وعلى نتنياهو ليجيب بدل مني قد
اكون في اجابتي البعض يعتبرها متحيزا نعم
هذه لها اسقاطات واذكرك في حاجه عن عندما
انسحب قائد
سريه ونائب قائد السريه قبل اربعه اسابيع
من المعركه بسبب حج حجه عدم تقديم اسلاد
النار الكافي كان لها وقعها المخزي على
جيش الاحتلال عندما يتم اخراج لواء كامل
اعتقد الالويه الاخرى ستتساءل كما يقال
يتلمس راسه طيب يعني اذا اذا احتاج كل هذا
الوقت لواء جولاني لكي يخرج من الخد
من الطبيعي ان تكون الالويه الاخرى قد
ايضا انهكت عانت عانت وبالتالي لن تحتاج
الى كل هذا الوقت الطويل لا يعني الان من
المؤكد انه الالويه الاخرى وقع بها خسائر
اقل من هذا اللواء لانها لم تكن في المق
نعم الان دعني اشير لنقطه لو كانت المشكله
مشكله معدات الجيش الاسرا جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لديه القدره على على تقديم
البدائل وارسال معدات بدل معدات رغم انه
اندفع
ميركافا ث ومفا ا لعدم كفايه وليس كفاءه
الميركافا عه لان المكاف تعتبر افضل سلاح
لديهم دفع بناق الجنود م 113 وتعود الى
ستينات القرن الماضي ليعزز خسائره
في في ناقله النمر
وايتان
وبتالي لو كانت المعضله فق في المعدات كان
يمكن ترميمها لكن لا
عندما يتحدث عن تدمير ناقله نحن نتحدث عن
11 الى 12 فرد في
الدبابه يتوزع بين قتيل وبين جريح وبين
مصاب بالمرض النفسي الم يتحدثوا ان 7% قبل
اسبوعين يعانوا من امراض نفسيه في في
الجيش الاحتلال وبالتالي هذا الامر له
اسقاطات ولا يعني لا استبعد اذا كان لدى
الجيش الاسرائيلي الجيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الجراه والمصداقيه في في تقديم
بيانات سيتحدث عن الويه اخرى تخرج من
المعركه قبل اقل من ساعتين قبل اقل من
ساعتين بن جانس ونتنياهو كرر الجمله
نفسها
لن تتوقف في الحرب سيستمر القتال حتى
تحقيق
الاهداف والان هذا الخبر سحب لواء جولاني
اميز وقوات النخبه من المعركه بمن
سيواصلون
القتال قلت لك لديهم الان يعني دعنا نعيد
صياغه الامر الجيش
الاسرائيلي الاحتياط مع القوات العامله
650,000 في بعض التقارير
و635 في تقارير اخرى لم يتم دعوه الاحتياط
كامل تم دعوه
300000 من الاحتياط لديه
الجيش طبعا انا لم اسال عن الكميه هنا
والعدد واضح واضح عندما سالت بمن سيواصل
القتال اقصد بايه اي روح معنويه نعم وايه
قوات يعني قوات الاحتياط ماذا يمكن ان
تقدم اذا كان اذا كان هذا اللواء يجب ان
نكون منصفين كذلك من ضمن من ضمن تنظيم هذا
اللواء معظم معظم كتائبه هي من قوات
الاحتياط يعني لتقولون نقطه واضحه للمشاهد
انه لواء لواء جولاني معظم وحداته هي من
قوات الاحتياط وقوات الاحتياط هي قوات
رئيسيه تتلقى التدريب الشهري طيب السنوي
عفوا بالاشاره الى الى هذا اللواء وجنوده
القناه الثالث عشره الاسرائيليه تقول ان
الجنود غادروا غزه لاعاده تنظيم صفوفهم
بالمنطق العسكري هل يخرج الجنود كل الجنود
التابع التابعين للواء معين يخرجون جميعا
الى خارج المعك لاعاده تنظيم الصف ساتوقف
عند التصريح قال تم سحب لواء جولاني اذا
تم سحب اللواء
كامل لا يسحب جزء ويبقي على جزء والان هذا
ما تحدث به يسمى اعاده بناء الجاهزيه
القتاليه لهذا اللواء سواء في بعد الاليات
والمعدات سواء في بعد البشري ام لكن هذا
سيحتاج الى وقت ليس خلال 24 ساعه سيعود
لواء جولاني يمكن يمكن ان يقوم باعاده
ترميم البناء الداخلي للواء عندما اتحدث
عن اربع كتائب دبابات خرج منها ولنفرض 40%
هو تبقى لديه لكن هذا الخساره ليست في
كتيبه واحده هي موزعه الان يعيد تجميع
المعدات القتاليه بدل اربع كتاب تصبح
باعتبارك خبيرا عسكريا في هذا المجال
لنفهم ماذا يعني اعاده تنظيم صفوف جنود
اللواء اعاده بناء الجاهزيه القتاليه له
وماذا تعني الجاهزيه القتاليه لانه عاده
الجاهزيه القتاليه المثاليه هي تكون 90%
من حجم من من من مكنون الموازنه لكل تشكيل
موازنه عامه اي افراد اليات بدءا من قائد
ال اللواء
وانتهاء باصغر جندي معروفه بالاعداد عندما
نقول انه في جاهزيه قتاليه كامله تكون
جاهزيته القتاليه 90% فما فوق وبالتالي
الان هو تعرض واصبحت جاهزيته القتاليه حسب
المقياس العالمي انا لا استطيع ان احدد كم
هي جاهزيته الان لكن افترض انه الاستاندرد
العالمي هو الفاصل في والمستند في حديثي
اصبحت جهزته القتاليه اقل من 60% الان هو
اصبح عنده نقص 30% حتى يعود الى المستوى
القتالي الاول هذا يخضع الى اكثر من اليه
لاعاده بناء الجاهزيه اما ان يعيد تجهيز
كتيبتين من اصل اربع كتائب دبابات وكتيبه
واحده من اصل كتيبتين مشاه واو يتم رفضه
من الخارج ولا اعتقد انه سيرفضه من الخارج
س سيقلص حجم اللواء وتصبح قدراته القتاليه
اقل من ح حث
الكم هنا ساعود الى نقطه سبق ان تحدثنا
عنها كثيرا وهي اعداد الضباط
الذين قتلوا وعندما يكون هذا اللواء في
ساحه المعركه والعديد من الضباط ومن رتب
مرتفعه قد قتلوا الا يؤثر ذلك على
هيكليه اللواء لواء جولاني وبتال بالتالي
هذا هو السبب الذي جعله يخرج لاعاده
التنظيم لانه حتى على مستوى القاده هو فقد
الكثير من القاده والضباط استاذ حسن الان
هذا اللواء قت لك يتشكل م ربع كتائب د عن
الاليات انا اتحدث عن الافراد اتحدث عن
الافراد الان لنفرض الكتيبه تتراوح
اعدادها تختلف من كتيبه الى كتيبه لكن
المعدل العام ما بين 350 الى 450 ضابط و
جندي في الكتيبه الواحده اذا اخذنا رقم ال
90 هو رقم الجها الجاهزيه القتاليه
المثاليه ليكن الان اذا لنفرض 400 متوسط
حسابي اذا نتحدث عن
370 فرد يجب ان يكون في هذه الوحده الان
عندما وقعت الخسائر في هذا اللواء هي وقعت
في كل تشكيلات اللواء لانه اللواء كان
بالمطلق منغمس في القتال لكن درجه الخسائر
تختلف من من وحده الى وحده الان لنفرض انه
هذا اللواء عديده 4500 جندي على افتراضا
الان خرج عن اطار العمل منهم 1500 بقي
لديه 3000 الان يعيد ترتيبهم وتوظيفهم في
في في تشكيل جديد فبدل ان يكون اربع كتائب
دبابات يصبح كتيبتي دبابات بدل كتيبتي
مشاه يصبح كتيبه مشاه اذا القدره القتاليه
الاجمال للواء تتقلص ويصبح لواء جولاني
بتنظيمه الجديد يتالف من كتيبتين دبابات
وكتيبه مش ومعنوياتنا اقل بالمطلق ام يعني
هذا هذا الجندي الذي خرج مهزوما هو لماذا
انسحب لانه لم يعد قادرا على ايداء واجبه
القتالي فهو بروح معنويه متدنيه مرهق له
53 يوم يقاتل
اي يحتاج الى فتره راحه وبالتالي هنا هذا
يسحب الى المنطقه الخلف
الى عمق فلسطين المحتله الى المعسكرات
النقب حتى يتم اعاده بنائه من جديد وهذا
عمليا عكس الصور التي يحاول ان ان ي جيش
الاحتلال يعني ليس فقط عكس الصور هذا ينقظ
مباشره تصريحات وزير الدفاع ومجلس الحرب
ونتنياهو حول حول تحقيق الاهداف ام الان
هو يقول وحتى
يعني المسؤولين الام ين تحدثوا قالوا اذا
حماس سلمت السلاح ورفعت الرا الرايه
البيضاء سيتوقف القتال نتنياهو ليس امامهم
الا الاستسلام او الموت وليس امامه الا
السجن
طيب لنعد ايضا الى الى المشاهد ونحن نتحدث
عن لواء لواء جولاني قلت بانه هناك الويه
اخرى يمكن ان تؤدي
المهمه حاليا بانتظار تنظيم صفوف هذا
الجيش وعودته مجددا الى ساحه المعركه نعم
الان هناك لواء جفعاتي هناك لواء نحال
هناك عندهم الويه مشاه وبالتالي الان انا
تحدث وقلت لك
اي اربعه فرق وتسعه الويه ام من التسعه
الويه خرج لواء الان الالوي الباقيه لا
يعني انها في قمه الجاهزيه القتاليه تعرضت
لخسائر لكن اقل مما تعرض له هذه اللواء قد
تكون جاهزيتها القتاليه وقدرتها العمليات
تراجعت على افتراض انه النسبه العاليه جدا
في في الجاهزيه القتاليه لحظه الدخول
بالحرب 90% قد نجد هناك لواء ب 75% لواء
70% لواء 80% اذا هذه الالويه اذا استمرت
الحرب هذه على طريقها ستسير في مسار لواء
جولاني وستخرج عاجلا ام اجلا من المعركه
وبالتالي انا قلت قبل قليل قلت ان المعركه
دخلت في اللحظات العصيبه من عض الاصابع
وان جيش الاحتلال غير قادر على تحمل تحمل
هذه الفاتوره
[موسيقى]
للمصادفة 14 وها هو وها ها هي الشجاعيه
تخرج لواء جولاني مره اخرى كما اذاقت
الهزيمه والمرار وقتل 70 عنصر من عناصره
في عام 2014 ها هي تجرع كاس المراره والذل
مره اخرى
اي لكن هو ربما ربما يكون هناك
علاقه بين الاعلان عن السيطره العمليات
على حي الشجاعيه قبل ان يتم الاعلان
عن سحب لواء جولاني من الم هو رساله
للداخل بانه الجيش الاحتلال يحقق انجازات
وفي طريقه لتحقيق المهمه والقضاء على حماس
وسيتم القبض على محمد ضيف
وارساله الى احد السجون داخل اسرائيل
ومحاكمته اي حسب القانون الاسرائيلي الذي
لا يعرف العدل ولا النزاهه لكن جاء جبر
على الاعلان لانه لو لم يعلن ستخرج ادعوت
احران او ارتس وتقول بان لواء
جولاني اصبح غير قادر على الاستمرار في
المعركه عليكم اخراجه طيب اكثر من مره سيد
فايز كنا نتناقش سويا حول الاعداد التي
يعترف بها جيش الاحتلال لعدد قتلاه
ومصابين وكنت دائما تقول هي اض اضعاف
اضعاف الان عندما يتم سحب لواء كواء
جولاني من المعركه هل
يمكن واذا اردنا ان نستند الى الرقم الذي
يفوق ال 140 بقليل 143
146 كحد اقصى هو الذي يعترف به جيش
الاحتلال هل هذه الخسائر تبرر سحب اي لواء
بهذا الشكل اولا هذه الخسائر هي ليست
مرتبطه بلواء جولاني هذه الخسائر مرتبطه
بالقوات التي شاركت
بالمعركه منذ السابع من من منذ المعركه
البريه وبالتالي قد يكون نصيب لواء جولاني
10% لنف 15% 20% لتكن
30% يعني هو فقد كم 45 جندي بحسب الاعتراف
بحسب الاعتراف الاسرائيلي هذا اللواء لا
يسحب الا اذا فقد 60% من من قدراته
القتاليه الماديه والبشريه وبالتالي هذا
هو ليجري حساباته ويخرج بالرقم انا ساجري
في هذه الليله الحسابات وساخر بالرقم
التقريبي ماذا فقد الان انا داخل الاستديو
لن استطيع الامساك بالاله الحاسبه واخراج
ال الارقام لكن سابذل جهدي ان اصل الى هذا
الرقم باقرب دقه هذا هذا الرقم هذا الرقم
خسائره في اقل من 48 ساعه او ثلاثه ايام
ليس في 53 يوم وبالتالي هو يكذب على شعبه
يكذب على شعبه اذا اخذت بتصريحات ابو
عبيده 720 اليه من كافه الانواع ل نقل 350
اليه مقاتله 400 اليه مقاتله اضربها في في
ثمانيه هي 200400 قتيل وجريح هذه مع يعني
بدي اعمل تصفيه نهايه العام الا يع عمل كل
عام تصفيه على بيع الملابس سعتم تصفيه
شارع اوكسفورد في لندن 50% عنده 2400 قتيل
وجريح فقط من خلال المعدات التي دمرت وليس
دا عن الجنود الذين قت قتلوا بشوا وير
اطلقت عليهم قنابل طيب لا يمكن ساتحمل لا
يمكن ان يكون عدد الجرحه لدى جيش الاحتلال
من بدايه المعركه البريه حتى هذه اللحظه
دون 11000 جريح يعني يعني ال 2800 الجرحه
الذين يعترف بهم جيش الاحتلال ايضا هذا
هذا لا لا لا هذا لا لا يمثل
25% يمكن ان نفهم من كلامك انه يستدل على
سحب اللواء ان اعداد القتلى مضاعفه
ومضاعفه بكثير مض انا
قلت قل تحدثت كثيرا ومعك قلت اذا اردت ان
تعرف خسائر العدو عليك ان تضرب بعشره واذا
اردت تت تعرف خسائر القسام وبقيه الفصائل
خذ التصريح الاسرائيلي واقسمه على عشره
ستبقى معادله العشره بالنسبه لك دارس طالب
محاسبه في قديما بانها هو الاساس المعتمد
في اجراء الحسابات السريعه لبيان الخسائر
طيب عاده هذا الكم من الخسائر
ام اذا استمر على نفس الوتيره او اذا
ارتفع نوعا ما مع مرور الايام عاده الجيوش
كم تستطيع ان تتحمل اي من من قتال يؤدي
الى هذه الخسائر ومن دون تحقيق الاهداف
المعلن هذا يعني لا يوجد مقياس عالمي يمكن
اعتماده نحن نتحدث عن حرب غير متناظره
نتحدث عن فارق قوه رهيب لا يمكن اجراء
مقارنه لا يمكن اجراء مقارنه وبالتالي كما
قلت لك هو دفع الان ب بالاعداد التي
ذكرتها لديه احتياطه الاستراتيجي لا يزال
لم يشترك في المعركه لديه المنطقه الوسطى
لا يجال يزال فيها قوات لديه المنطقه
الشماليه لا يزال لديه قوات وبالتالي هو
يستطيع دعنا نستثني جزئيا المنطقه
الشماليه دعنا نستثني جزئيا القوات لانه
تقريبا 255% من قواته في المنطقه الشماليه
30% في الضفه الغربيه والبقيه موجوده في
الجنوب الان يستطيع ان يسحب ويرفض لا يزال
لديه موفور قوه يجب ان لا ننكر ذلك
وبالتالي لديه القدره لكن ال العم
دعني افرق بين القدره على زج قوات اضافيه
والقدره على تحمل الخسائر هذه وهذا تحديدا
ما هذه هي المعادله هذا تحديدا ما ما قص
هذه هي المعادله حسن يعني الان يجب ان
اقارن لديه القدره على الدفع بقوات اضافيه
لكن هل لديه القدره على تحمل الخسائر هذه
هي النقطه وبالتالي لو لو الشارع داخل
الكيان الاسرائيلي يعلم يقينا نس عداد
القتلى والجرحى والمرضى نفسيين لاسقط
نتنياهو اتذكر المظاهرات عندما تم
الاحتجاج على تعديل القانون المحكمه
العليا ستكون نفس الو الحالي نعم طيب
سؤال يعني المعروف
عند قول دائما يتردد لا يمكن تغيير القاده
في اثناء
المعركه لكن كما كما نلاحظ ان هناك
خلافات بين القاده الاسرائيليين في اثناء
المعركه وبالتالي هذا اللواء الذي تعرض
للعديد من الكمائن والخسائر والاستهداف في
حي الشجاعيه ب بالذات فجر خلافات بين
القاده العسكريين الاسرائيليين هنا هل
يمكن ل لهذا ان يؤثر على الهيكليه
القياديه العسكريه في اسرائيل الان مجلس
الحرب لا يزال متماسك رغم الخلافات
البينيه لانه الان اذا تحدثنا عن مجلس
الحرب تدخل السياسه ضمن اطار القياده
والخلافات السياسيه والصراعات السياسيه
يعني لا يمكن ان نفصل خاصه في داخل الكيان
الاسرائيلي بسبب طبيعه التنظيمات السياسيه
من اليسار الذي تهالك وانتهى الى اليمين
الذي ت تشظى الى مستويات مختلفه اقصى
اليمين ووسط اليمين ويسار اليمين ومن ثم
نذهب باتجاه اليسار التقليدي الخلافات
موجوده اي بين ازن كوت ووزير الدفاع
ونتنياهو لكن الظرف الحالي لا يزالوا
يصروا على انهم موحدين اذا ما تعمقت ماساه
جولاني وانتقلت الى جفعاتي والى ناحوم
وغيرها لا
ست
ستتشارك امم التغيير القاضي يجري وحتى في
البعد العسكري اذا ذهبنا الى الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا كم جرى تغيير قيادات
في طرفي الصراع في الجانب الروسي والجانب
الاوكراني وزراء دفاع الجانب الاوكراني
تغير قاده جيوش رؤساء اركان تغيروا قاده
جيوش قاده فيالق في الجانب الروسي تغيروا
عندما يفشل القائد في اداره المعركه يمكن
استبداله
ابرز مثال ابرز مثال في تاريخ تغيير
القاده ن في شمال افريقيا بعد معركه عالم
حل قبل معركه حلفا كانت بني يعني عانت
قوات البريطانيه في جمله واحده في كثير من
الخسائر فتم تغييرهم وجلب احضار الجنرال
مونت جمري الذي حل محل القائد السابق وقلب
ظهر المجن شكرا شكرا لك اللواء فاز
الدويري